we are going to do a full review today
of CPAC 2023 the conservative political
action conference happening in
Washington DC Under The Cloud of uh
sexual assault charges against its
organizer Matt schlapp now Donald Trump
closed out the speech on Saturday
delivering what I believe is his most
dangerous and unhinged speech yet
closing out what is not only a
deplorable conference but a conference
that really gave me confidence that
Donald Trump is still in control of the
loudest wing of the Republican party and
he is the candidate to beat in the 2024
Republican primary after everything
that's happened after everything we've
been through his presidency losing in
2020 spending years claiming it was
rigged announcing he's running 2024 all
of it Trump showed up and gave one of
the scariest and most delusional
authoritarian speeches that he has ever
given and that is saying a lot because
he's given what hundreds thousands of
these speeches impossible to fact check
hundreds of Lies why Trump swollen we
never know his right eye almost
completely swollen shut going a nearly
two castro-like hours in length a couple
of glitches it wasn't the glitchiest
speech but Trump stumbling once again
with United States crazy the racist
Manhattan district attorney Alvin Bragg
who is presiding over one of the most
dangerous and violent cities in the
United States the United States and
Trump continuing to struggle with States
later calling them Spates
and I'll challenge the governors of all
50 states that's right if you are
currently governing any of the states
Trump is coming for you one other funny
moment before we get into the scary part
the speech briefly interrupted by
someone playing really loud music and
then protesters started to boot our
country I'm sorry the his Trump's fans
started to boo the guy playing the loud
music for that love our country have
been so great on that issue and the
Pervert to use the names of Washington
and Lincoln to buy millions of dollars
in ads to say bad liveless and incorrect
things about us
so Trump yelling over the music and the
people uh yelling at the music guy
thank you
all right so a couple funny moments but
then it got very scary and very
dishonest just a sampling of Lies Donald
Trump said that while he was President
he finished some Wars which I I couldn't
I'm not aware of trump ending any wars
the only president in modern history who
did not have
any new Wars no new Wars I finished some
ogles
uh fact Checkers unable to find any wars
that Donald Trump finished a big theme
of the speech Trump going hard at
Republicans of course going after the
leftist Marxist communist socialists of
course but going very aggressively
against Republicans signaling this is
going to be a disgustingly chippy and
dirty primary here is Trump calling out
Mitch McConnell and you know we all want
to see success but it's far more
important to them than it is to us
because of that location we are never
going to
be a country ruled by entrenched
political dynasties in both parties
rotten special interests china-loving
politicians of which there are many
you're listening to this Mitch McConnell
are you listening
and the crowd liking the Civil War
Friendly Fire
[Applause]
[Music]
frightened of telling the truth or is
truly evil and bad I don't know yeah
Trump doesn't know Trump then spending
more time going after Jeb Bush and Karl
Rove and Paul Ryan a lot of Friendly
Fire here when we started this journey a
journey like there has never been before
there's never been anything like this
we had a Republican party that was ruled
by Freaks neocons
globalists open border zealots
and fools
but we are never going back to the party
of Paul Ryan Karl Rove and Jeb Bush
and Trump is honest in the sense that if
he is going to have a shot the
Republican party can't go back to Paul
Ryan Karl Rove in Jeb Bush because if
they did Trump trump would be out on his
ass quite frankly Donald Trump seemed to
suggest that he really believed many of
the people who back in 2020 told him
listen you're going to be back in the
Oval Office in six weeks less
used to say four years a lot of people
said well sir
the election was so bad you'll be in in
one year a lot of people in this room
you'll be back in six weeks sir
but it's a bad system in many ways very
yeah it's a system that doesn't have a
process for reinstating a president
after someone else has been president
for six weeks that's what Trump is
bemoaning there we've got a bad process
you know people came to me sir they said
they were crying they said sir you'll be
back in five weeks Biden so bad and then
our system wouldn't allow it Trump found
out that's right we don't have a system
we have a line of succession that goes
from the president to the vice president
to the Secretary of State and then on
down uh uh it doesn't act the speaker of
the house it doesn't actually go to the
guy who lost the last election that is
true that is not the system that we have
Trump then talking about the wall and
this is the moment at which Trump's
sanity was most questioned Trump seems
to say that they hid the wall Biden took
the border wall with Mexico and he hit
it some wear so that it wouldn't be used
the wall was sitting there waiting to be
installed the easiest part
Arizona couldn't use it Texas and
Arizona said could we
use that wall we'll finish it right up
and they said no and they actually took
it away and they hid it they put it in a
hiding area which of course was revealed
pretty quickly all you have to do is
send a couple of helicopters up that's
right but they wouldn't let him use it
under my leadership what on Earth is
this guy talking about they hid the wall
they moved the wall and hid it but then
with some helicopters Trump figured out
where Biden hid his border wall that
this is delusional stuff I can't think
of a charitable interpretation of what
on Earth Trump is talking about then
Trump using really strange language
talked about baby bonuses now there is
actually a policy connection here let me
first play for you the deranged Insanity
that Trump said but then I want to say
more about it challenge the governors of
all 50 states all 50 states to join me
in a great beautification campaign we
will rename our schools and boulevards
not after Communists but after Great
American Patriots right
we will get rid of bad and ugly
buildings and return to the Magnificent
classical style of Western Civilization
wow
we will support Baby Boomers and we will
support baby bonuses
for a new baby boom how does that sound
that sounds pretty I want a baby boom
so what's interesting about this is on
the one hand it's very reminiscent of
Hitler's mother's cross which was a
program to encourage Germans to have
kids but on the other hand there's this
thing called the child tax credit which
Joe Biden and Democrats would like to
make permanent a higher tax credit for
children which in a way is kind of what
Trump is talking about although the the
child tax credit isn't to encourage
people to have children it's to provide
financial support for those who do but
Republicans are against making that
permanent so it's all just a weird
mishmash sort of a verbal uh inkblot
test of sorts Trump also taking shots
not only at Republicans but at Fox News
during this deranged speech which by the
way carried the speech not too good and
we actually have to say this
I hope Fox doesn't turn off but we did
much better in 2020 than we did in 2016.
right
I mean you didn't
but we have no choice not in the sense
that you lost anyway Donald Trump again
Reviving this idea of sending people
addicted to drugs and who just are
homeless to tent cities sort of like
camps of sorts remember they would
always accuse Barack Obama he's going to
send you to a camp Trump quite literally
is saying that's what he wants to do
take a listen
oh no
looks like this particular clip may be
glitching
let's see if I if I can fix that for my
audience here
I do believe that I can I have
confidence that I can here we go
leadership we will take the homeless
drug addicted and severely deranged get
them off our streets and create 10
cities where we will get them the help
they so desperately need right
and the crowd reacting pretty positively
to that
Trump also uh wrongly claiming by the
way that so-called foreign mental
institutions and quote insane asylums
are being emptied into the United States
that's not happening by the way they're
emptying out their prisons and you've
heard me say that but they're also
emptying out their mental institutions
and what uh to use a strong couple of
words insane asylum insane asylum that's
where anybody see Silence of the Lamb
that's where they come from Silence of
the Lamb uh has been emptied Anthony hop
basically undocumented immigrant
versions of Anthony Hopkins are just
being released into the country none of
that is going on just so people know
Trump at one point asks whether anyone
has watched TV everybody you ever see
television you know it used to be
we'd build our military we were proud of
it would be doing all things would be
all you see on thing investigation
investigation investigation now with
that being said
you got to look at Hunter I mean how
crooked is that deal but right no and
often going back to the topic of Hunter
Biden and then Donald Trump talking
about uh with really really strange
language how he is the retribution he is
now talking about retribution and
revenge this was maybe the most
dictatorial moment of the speech other
than like 40 other moments that were
almost as dictatorial in 2016 I declared
I am your voice today I add I am your
Warrior I am your Justice and for those
who have been wronged and betrayed
I am your retribution I am your
retribution I don't even think Trump
knows what he's talking about he wrote
something people told him but it's
really really scary dystopian stuff
Trump at one point on a very strange
word salad about
um oil and gas and electric vehicles we
have oil and gas but we don't want the
but we want everything including
electric cars but we also want gasoline
because the cars go longer oh and they
are preferred by many people
pretty Crystal Clear position huh
we don't like quick drives that have
stopped for two and a half hours
yep Trump is not pleased with the range
of electric vehicles and then Trump
bringing out the L word lynching saying
that they are looking to Lynch him
of course he is the ultimate victim as
many of you know
and unfortunately another very glitchy
clip here I don't know what is causing
these glitches uh and I hate to ever be
unprepared for my audience uh but a
couple a couple of glitchy Clips here
let's continue
what the hell did you get me into yeah
[Applause]
his words grand jury I didn't know that
they want to Lynch you for doing nothing
wrong I didn't know they want to Lynch
you for doing a great job I didn't know
they want to put you away because your
poll numbers are better than anybody
they've seen in years yeah Trump's best
poll numbers so a few thoughts about
this speech obviously Trump telling
hundreds of Lies delusional dangerous
authoritarian one notable thing from
Trump's very long speech is that while
he did attack Paul Ryan and Mitch
McConnell and Karl Rove and Jeb Bush and
rhinos he didn't overtly go after any of
the 2024 Republican contenders or
would-be contenders like the santis he
didn't even allude to DeSantis in this
particular speech that's interesting and
unclear what the strategy there is Trump
did make claims that CPAC was packed
Trump's speech was the most full of any
of the events and it was only about 85
percent full many of the other events
very much empty and then another thing
is the crowd really didn't seem that
energized NBC News uses Benjamin goggin
tweeted a picture and said as Trump's
speech bleeds over to the one hour mark
a notable number of people they're
filtering out Matt Gates slipped out
early shaking hands in the aisle energy
tonight is much sleepier than last
year's Trump CPAC speech I am
increasingly convinced that Donald Trump
as the Republican nominee is the best
thing for Democrats particularly after
seeing the this speech I will talk more
about that tomorrow let's now move on to
a few other things Carrie Lake spoke at
least twice at CPAC based on the number
of outfit changes she said a lot of
extremely bizarre things I don't know
how much longer Carrie lake has to be
paid attention to now if she does run
for Senate in Arizona in 2024
she will get another round of attention
but here is Carrie Lake crowning Stephen
Bannon the fox the indicted and
convicted uh Breitbart propaganda
Steve Bannon she says he's like George
Washington Steve
yeah where's that
Washington
in what way really really weird and as
we as you know Kerry lake is one of the
sickest people in politics right now at
another moment during one of her two
CPAC speeches she talked about how God
told her all about the things she's
doing and it really sounds like the type
of thing that should be explored
um in therapy quite frankly God placed
us at this moment for a reason I talked
about my moment with God where he told
me you're going to do something special
someday someday and I don't know what it
is it may still be to come who knows but
I know that putting me in the center of
all of this with my fighting spirit I
believe that God is truly in control at
this moment and we win I believe we win
at the end of the day
he plays mild Applause for that and part
of it is the her she didn't have big
crowds she's here for a reason right
he doesn't make accidents he doesn't he
doesn't
accidentally places where we are we are
here for a reason just the same as our
founding fathers at that pivotal moment
where place where they were in 1776.
part of Year Sam Adams Patrick Henry and
what we're facing right now is no
different yep in the same way that God
placed Paul Revere in a position to be
one of the founders he placed Kerry Lake
in a position to I guess lose the
governorship of Arizona and then lastly
and again this seems to be a different
Carey Lake speech because she's wearing
different clothes she is now telling the
story that someone tried to bribe her
out of politics tell me if you believe
this story nothing happened to me this
week before I left for CPAC and it shows
are to stop me and to silence you
I decided to share this it's a little
bit controversial but I'm going to put
this out
somebody showed up at my door whoa this
week they called me before and said I
gotta talk to you in person this can't
be done over the phone she's always kind
of like uh oh what's that going to be
about
they came to my door and they tried to
bribe me out of getting out of politics
and they said sir
it's really happened now by the way did
you listen to the exact word she used
listen to that they called me before and
said I got talk to you in person this
can't be done over the phone which is
always kind of like uh oh what's that
going to be about
they came to my door and they tried to
bribe me out of getting out of politics
she now that's not what she means she's
her control command of the English
language is so poor she said they tried
to bribe me bribe me out of getting out
of politics in other words they wanted
to pay her to stay in politics but
that's not what she actually means it's
another one of these accidental double
negatives and you'd think for someone
who spent so much time talking on TV she
would be able to better explain herself
but anyway she doesn't mean bribe me out
of getting out of politics she means
they tried to bribe me out of politics
okay
it's really happened I'm telling you
this because this is how disgusting
politics is
a mom who runs for office and they're
afraid of me
they tried to bribe me with a job title
with a huge salary a position on a board
this is how they do it
and I said are you kidding me
I walked away from a big job and a big
salary I'm not motivated by that stuff
guys all right anyway so she'll
hopefully keep losing elections but
Carrie Lake out of out of this world do
you believe that story that she just
told
I have a real hard time believing it all
of these clips will be on our YouTube
channel youtube.com the davidpackman
show make sure you are subscribed folks
hit that subscribe button on the YouTube
channel and remember you can find these
clips in Spanish at davidpackman.com
Spanish
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
remember that we are an audience
supported program and if you'd like to
do just a little something to help us
you can sign up at joinpakman.com you'll
get access to an extra show that we do
every day when you become a member it's
cheap it's quick it's easy and it keeps
us independent
joinpakman.com is the place to sign up
all right let's look at some humorous
and funny moments from CPAC 2023 these
are some of my favorite moments from a
comedic standpoint some of you may
remember that 2024 Republican
presidential candidate Nikki Haley
suggested a competency or cognitive test
for any politician age 75 or older now
she overtly meant this for Joe Biden but
part of her campaign against Trump has
been that she's younger and she's from
the Next Generation and so we know that
when she talks about cognitive tests for
those 75 and over
she also means and it would apply to
Donald Trump well the CPAC crowd is very
Maga friendly and they weren't going for
it and when Nikki Haley suggests the
cognitive tests the mental competency
tests the crowd is silent you could hear
a pin drop in there not a Nikki Nikki
Haley friendly crowd and I absolutely
love it look at this when I launched my
campaign I said every politician over 75
years old should be required to take a
mental competency test
have you seen DC lately
dead silent
dead silent we should start with Joe
Biden and we shouldn't stop there
okay one person did clap one person did
clap this and many other Clips we're
going to look at today
for me were reminders that this is
Trump's party this genuinely is Trump's
party now I know Nikki Haley spoke I
know Vivek ramaswamy spoke who's also
running for president against Trump but
this was a trump crowd this was a Maga
crowd they love Steve Bannon they loved
Bo bear and Marjorie Taylor green and
the entire thing Kerry Lake they cheered
for all of the election lies and the
entire thing and this is quite frankly
Trump's nomination to lose this is a
line that's done okay in some of the
early primary States when Nikki goes by
herself and it's a nikki-friendly crowd
but CPAC is trumpy Trump is 76 and they
recognize that to some degree what Nikki
Haley is saying would apply to Trump and
they don't like it so a hilarious and
humiliating moment for Nikki Haley here
is maybe the funniest of all of these
moments Ben Carson Trump's former
secretary Terry of Hud
and former presidential candidate former
neurosurgeon I think he went so long at
CPAC that they started playing music you
know how at the Oscars you go up and
after 30 seconds of thanking people they
start playing music to try to get you
off
Ben Carson wouldn't stop talking and
they played music and the music repeated
it was like 30 seconds of Music they
never they didn't think we'll need to go
longer than 30 seconds of music with
anybody but Ben Carson kept talking and
talking and talking
and they just kept playing the music
over and over again and he seemed
completely unaware of what's going on
when they go to Newsmax even the people
on Newsmax seem to feel bad for him
check this out say college students
young staffers what you need to know
about the government so that you don't
have to so that you can hit the ground
running because we need to get these
people he's in the middle of his speech
and they're playing him off because 90
of the of the career employees or people
who live in this area who have the
politics in this area and slow things
down and push things forward we've got
to be able to do much better than that
by understanding this process so that's
what the EBA is all about so now the
crowd is trying to help them by clapping
and sort of like okay let's rap but he
just keeps going
and this will help us to determine and
answer the question
which Benjamin Franklin said if we can
keep it when he starts going into quotes
you know he's not ending It's a
Wonderful system that we have don't let
anybody tell you anything that's
different from that but we're the ones
who are going to have to do it did you
notice the music stopped and now they're
cycling it again they're like we gotta
get him off and he just keeps going and
if you want to know can we keep it find
a World War II veteran and ask him what
was going through their head and D-Day
when they are on the shores of Normandy
and all of those people were being shot
and they stepped over those dead bodies
knowing in many cases they would never
see their loved ones or their Homeland
again
why did they do it
for you
oh this guy is unbelievable oh and I
just lost it where did that go oh my
goodness that was crazy
where did that speech go we got to get
it back
um eventually he walks away that was
crazy the the speech just went away uh
you've got to see the end because even
the Newsmax hosts seem to be recognizing
what's going on here it is
so that we can live in peace and safety
ask them if we can keep it we can with
all of us thank you so much all right so
there you go
[Applause]
all right Dr Ben Carson
um uh a good speech a good solid speech
one that folks seem to enjoy however it
could it's not lost on myself or Tom
basili who joins us right now who's the
host of America right now
um that they were playing the music I
mean they're behind that's not his fault
yeah no it's not lost on any of us
believe me sir so there is Ben Carson
bringing his electric personality to
CPAC in it going about as well as we
would expect let's now talk about
Kimberly Guilfoyle Donald Trump Jr's
fiancee Kimberly Guilfoyle
absolutely rocked a room full of about
12 people
she is doing everything she can in this
clip to energize the crowd but when the
camera pans to the crowd you see there's
only about a dozen or 15 people in the
crowd it's it's just unbelievable ever
you couldn't write
anything more pathetic than what
actually happened so listen to this and
if you're only listening and not
watching understand that when you hear
the crowd there's like 15 people there I
have all
of all this room have one message to Joe
Biden it is time to put America first
[Applause]
oh God look at this crowd a lot of the
people don't even seem to be watching
the speech one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
thirteen fourteen fifteen sixteen
Seventeen eighteen nineteen
20 21 22 23 there okay so there's like
30 people in a room that could fit maybe
like 800 or something like that it is
shocking how humiliating this is
to put common sense all right and then
one other humiliating moment from
Kimberly Guilfoyle as if it wasn't bad
enough that's she was doing some kind of
show I guess she has a show on Rumble
now she did her show from CPAC and she
tries to sell silver and gold and she's
reading everything off of a teleprompter
to her right and it's awkward and it's
weird and it's strange and I want to
make sure that you
got it gold and silver can protect your
retirement savings from inflation and
dollar devaluation and owning tangible
physical inflation hedging gold and
silver can help diversify your portfolio
you've got to have a diversified
portfolio everybody knows that
everyone's of Americans diversify and
protect their retirement savings support
companies who support you it makes sense
doesn't it instead of supporting both
companies who hate you and use your
money to further their political agenda
yeah so go to Kim's medals it's kind of
catchy.com to learn more that's
kimsmetals.com okay so there it is and
making a very powerful investment
suggestion is Kimberly Guilfoyle a
completely absurd CPAC I mean you you
could say I'm guessing Saturday Night
Live can't do anything with it because
it it's a parody of itself and uh
Kimberly Guilfoyle Ben Carson all of
these people Nikki Haley they are just
debasing themselves relentlessly and I
have to be honest I I absolutely love to
see it let's take a quick break remember
that all of these clips will be on our
Instagram which you can find by
searching Instagram for David Pacman
show
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show one of my
favorite things is when the conspiracy
theorists agree about the conspiracy but
with conflicting evidence to support it
this happens with flat earthers all the
time you've got flat earthers who
believe the Earth is flat but they will
prove quote prove the Earth is flat with
contradictory EV quote evidence and one
of them has to be wrong and I just
absolutely love it and we have an
example from CPAC as many of you know
one of the big lie election conspiracy
theories is that
um part of how Democrats quote cheat is
with early voting and mail-in voting and
so there's a lot of Republicans who say
we just we've got to have one day of
voting and if you're a republican
definitely vote on Election Day so that
they don't mess with your vote but there
are others in the Republican Party who
are now realizing wait a second if the
Democrats vote early in by mail and we
don't they get like three weeks of
voting and we get one day that's not
good so here we have a clip uh Steve
Bannon and MyPillow CEO Mike Lindell
interviewing being interviewed whatever
and it starts to happen that there's
this disagreement wait are we is the
problem that we're not voting early or
should we or not this is this is just
absolute gold of the it's an example of
the mayonnaise that their brains have
been turned into game day voting yes
Steve we're gonna get wiped out again
you can
[Music]
there's no mathematical equation that is
going to win you an election it's great
to talk about it's fun you get fired up
they've got 55 days to get balance in
and we're giving ourselves 15 hours if
we continue this we'll never win again
now
I don't think this guy's wrong in the
sense that
there is no voter fraud the way they
claim there is
and if you do restrict yourself only to
the people who can vote on Election Day
whereas Democrats are saying I'll vote
when it's convenient if there's early
voting I'll do that or I'll mail in by
ballot you are hurting yourself that is
true is it isn't that what they did to
Cary Lake we had the camera that's why
they had to turn the machines off Steve
and they if they do it the way sin you
know he's just misconstrued you can't
overrun an algorithm and you can't
overrun a computer you have to do it the
way I'm telling you I like the woman in
the back nodding as if she has any idea
what pillow's talking about hold on hold
on here's where I propose in the war
rule do it rev we have to have a debate
on our side of the football because
there's clearly two camps and your
Camp's probably 65-35 but we need
everybody 100 on one or the other
because this is critical so we I commit
that we're going to do this when we get
everybody involved into town isn't this
the best they're going to hold a town
hall to argue should we use the methods
that the Democrats are using for fraud
or should we not but then we hurt
ourselves it it's unbelievable that
they're doing this to themselves said
every state is different their states
that John will be right in that's what
we're doing with the bureau we're
investing look at the footprint of the
state and what's the best thing to do in
that state some of these states uh
um you can vote a week early like in
Texas they don't have a lot of time to
pull from border rawson's Ah that's so
so pillow now is coming up with a sort
of new conspiracy theory which is listen
in states where there isn't much early
voting there it's okay to vote early
because they don't have time to execute
the fraud that they can do with the
machines when you vote like really early
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines so then later
pillow was interviewed by right side
broadcasting and now he is calling this
the new big lie now let me tell you the
big lie the new big lie yeah okay and
comes from Republicans
and it's most of it's the establishment
but there's a few people in our in here
that still that they've because of what
happened in Arizona they believe this
what happened is everyone's saying and
this is like even the RNC when I was
there running for the chair they're
going
um we've got to do like the Democrats
vote early look what happened in Arizona
what if something goes wrong with the
machine we got to vote early on ballot
Harvest and and drop boxes and you know
if you can't fight them join them if you
do that we lose our country we have
fought two years to do same day born and
get rid of these machines two years
you're gonna destroy everything we
fought for now the funny thing is pillow
has been fighting for two years but
they're not any closer to getting rid of
early voting and mail-in voting this is
fantastic and this is the exact type of
fight that we should allow them to have
amongst themselves well we just remember
hey let's vote let's let's vote however
it is because these stories about
widespread election fraud have not been
substantiated in the least but we want
them wasting their time with this sort
of nonsense because it's a black hole
for them it's a complete and total black
hole hold Town Halls do all of it argue
about whether or not to vote early
meanwhile we'll just keep trying to get
people registered and convincing people
about the importance of voting in the
first place okay one of the last things
from CPAC that we're going to talk about
and and many so many of you emailed me
about this
is the Michael Knowles anti-transgender
moment now before I play this clip of
Michael Knowles and remember this is one
of the daily wire guys and I've been on
his program a couple of times and I
stopped doing it because I really got
nothing out of it and just you know his
audience doesn't like me and my audience
already knows me and there was just no
there's no benefit to going and arguing
with him about nonsense so
uh for a couple years now
the anti-trans and homophobic lines get
the best reactions at CPAC the CPAC
crowds have been increasingly dead
um other than when they do anti-trans or
homophobic stuff we saw it from Trump
last year we saw it from Ted Cruz at
some recent CPAC where he said my
pronouns are kiss my ass and you know
the anti-trans anti-home of the anti-gay
stuff still does really well
and Matt Walsh who's another one of
these daily wire guys has really found a
lucrative niche in doing the anti-tran
stuff so clearly Michael Knowles is
trying to copy it he's saying hey whoa
the gravy train with the anti-tran stuff
is working really well for Matt Walsh
let me jump in on it so he's talked
about the need to eliminate
transgenderism so this is an example of
the anti-tran stuff from CPAC take a
look there can be
with transgenderism it is all or nothing
if transgenderism is true if men really
can become women then it's true for
everybody of all ages if transgenderism
is false as it is if men really can't
become women as they cannot
then it's false for everybody too now I
wanna let me address this for a moment
um they insist on this thing where they
want to know the truth about whether a
man can be a woman or whether a woman
can be a man and they want to argue
about it's all it's just truth and
biology Neil deGrasse Tyson in an
interview with Ben Shapiro a few weeks
ago made a really good point which is
listen
the TR if you want to talk about the
unassailable facts undeniable no one can
deny this the undeniable fact is that
people Express gender on a spectrum you
you can't deny that okay it is an
absolutely
incontrovertible truth that there is a
spectrum of gender expression for all
birth biological sex that exists people
Express gender on a spectrum you've got
more and less feminine men
and on and on so as Neil deGrasse Tyson
eloquently said there are aspects of
this which are questions for a biology
class there are aspects of this which
are questions for a Sociology class
there are aspects of this that are
questions for sports leagues to
determine rules no doubt and we've got
to figure out where that is but if you
want to talk about facts it is a fact
that people Express gender on a spectrum
and so when they talk about we just want
the truth can a man be a woman it's one
of the worst Faith but also ignorant
things you can say because all you need
to do is look at the world around you
and you know that it is true that gender
is expressed on a spectrum they they
want to make it a conversation about
something else let's listen to the last
few seconds and if it's false
[Applause]
especially since that Indulgence
requires taking away the rights and
customs of so many people if it is false
that's it for the good of society and
especially for the good of the poor
people who have fallen prey to this
confusion
transgenderism must be eradicated from
public life entirely now
numerous headlines after this speech
said oh he wants to get rid of
transgender people he just he wants to
get rid of him that's absolutely
horrible and Michael Knowles and other
people associated with him
have come to his defense with a line
like that's not true he didn't say do
anything to the people he said get rid
of the ism get eradicate transgenderism
not kill the trans people now I think we
need only one very simple hypothetical
to explore whether that is a good faith
defense of what Michael Knowles said
imagine imagine
that Michael Knowles or whoever had said
we need to eradicate Judaism
oh my God are you calling for for
genocide no no no no I didn't say
anything about eradicating Jews I meant
eradicate Judaism completely
do you think we would all accept that
and go oh okay
it's fine he's not saying anything about
Jews he's just saying eradicate Judaism
get rid of it completely oh yeah the
Anti-Defamation League would be fine
with that defense this is a pathetic
attempt to soften but also put others on
the defensive and some went for it there
are some news outlets that after Knowles
complained changed their headlines and
uh we all know what he's talking about
he is using he is saying out loud
in more explicit terms what a ton of
these right Wingers are thinking and
it's dangerous and it's disgusting and
it needs to be condemned and he can't be
allowed to walk it back by going no no I
didn't say anything about trans people I
met just get rid of the ism well what do
you what exactly do you mean by that
um this is what they are getting the
biggest reactions to we started seeing
it a year or two ago we've done
interviews about it the anti-lgbt and
now specifically focused on anti-trans
stuff it is back
they are going to ride it to a pot of
gold if they are allowed to Matt Walsh
already did Michael Knowles is trying
for it I would like to see some
Republicans if this is a great
opportunity for Mitt Romney this is a
great opportunity for whoever wants to
come forward and say that I have to
condemn let's see if any of them do
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
the dangerous and unhinged CPAC speech
wasn't Trump's only public declaration
at CPAC in Washington DC over the
weekend he also gave a very strange
Press Conference during which he came
out looking extraordinarily paled
disheveled and even visibly confused he
took a few questions and there are just
a few moments here that I want to
highlight for you one of the topics that
we've been talking about recently is
this loyalty pledge the Republican
National Committee wants all of the
Republican candidates to sign a loyalty
pledge wherein they will say in exchange
for being allowed on the debate stage I
will eventually support whoever is the
Republican nominee now we've been going
back and forth is that something that
Trump would be willing to agree to or
not one side is no of course he's not
going to agree to it the other side is
sure he'll agree to it if he needs to in
order to get on the stage but then he
won't abide by it well Trump was
actually asked about the Loyalty pledge
and at least for now he seems to be
saying I don't know there's some people
running that I wouldn't be big on
supporting so unclear whether that
loyalty pledges something he's going to
go for let's take a listen
Mr President a lot of the people we
talked to
them
well I don't know I mean I'm just
hearing about it for the first time
about the Loyalty pleasure probably
people that I wouldn't be very happy
about endorsing you know running so
we'll see I think some of them I won't
use names I don't want to insult any but
but some of them I would not be very
happy about so we'll have to think about
that yeah so Trump's saying
fundamentally and this is an honest
answer right there are people running or
potentially running or likely running
that he wouldn't actually want to
support so he's going to have to think
about it now I still think that the
truth is when push comes to shove Trump
if he absolutely needs to get on the
debate stage he will sign whatever he
will say whatever he wants to be on the
debate stage and if that's going to
prevent him if not signing the Loyalty
pledge we'll keep him off the debate
stage he'll just sign it and then if it
comes down to he loses the nomination
and then he wants to run as an
independent he'll just ignore it he'll
say you know when I signed it I didn't
assume they would rig it against me or
whatever I still think that that is the
most likely thing these pledges promises
they mean absolutely nothing to Donald
Trump at another moment Donald Trump was
asked about some of the things that Mike
Pompeo
his own former secret one of his own
former secretaries of State said during
pompeo's own CPAC speech and Pompeo said
we don't need celebrity nominees and
Trump was asked do you think Pompeo was
talking about you and Trump basically
says I don't see myself as a celebrity
so probably not yesterday
who refuse to acknowledge reality was he
talking about you do you have a response
no I don't think he was talking about me
I don't consider myself a celebrity
leader I consider myself a leader of the
country but I don't consider myself a
celebrity leader how insane is this I
didn't do this for the celebrity uh
maybe it helped me get elected who knows
but I don't consider that I consider
myself a person that was President for
four years Trump doesn't consider
himself a celebrity of course the
reality is were Trump not a celebrity
celebrity he never would have become the
Republican nominee to begin with but
okay he can live in whatever fantasy
world he wants to live in and then
lastly the topic came up during this
press conference Trump gave
of if you are indicted will you still
run for president and Trump said he
would here's like a little report on
this from ABC Trump himself faces
multiple state and federal criminal
investigations and lawsuits but he told
reporters none of them will force him
out of the race even if he is indicted
absolutely I wouldn't even think about
leaving well Trump dominated CPAC
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis spoke this
weekend at the Reagan Library okay so
Trump's saying he would absolutely stay
in if he is indicted now I think that
that statement is meaningless and what I
mean by that is
Trump has no choice but to say he would
stay in because if he says oh no no no
if I'm indicted I'm leaving he
immediately short circuits donations he
short circuits support because there
will be people who will hear that and
say oh wait a second am I going to
support this guy or donate to this guy
if he bails if he's indicted no so
regardless of what the truth is Trump
has to say he would stay in in reality
in practice if Trump is indicted
depending on what the charges are
depending on what's going on I think it
will potentially affect his race now
whether he actually bails or whether it
just destroys his chances of winning are
two different scenarios which we can
discuss at some future point but I think
Trump has no choice but to say exactly
this at this point in time and we'll see
what the truth is if and when it happens
and by the way reports are that the
indictment may come down anytime as I
like to say it could come down today or
never that's the range anytime between
today and never Trump could be indicted
Sean Hannity on his radio show was
confronted by a caller saying dude you
lied on air you knew Trump didn't really
win in 2020 we know from the text
messages that were revealed and we know
from Rupert Murdoch's deposition under
oath we know you were lying when you
went on air and said oh there was fraud
and Trump really won and all of this
different stuff
and Hannity
tries to backpedal and explain away and
it is a delight to see this uh is from
the Ari melber MSNBC show where they
compiled a bunch of different things the
back story of course is that on air on
Fox after the 2020 election Hannity and
Laura Ingram and Tucker and many others
were uh pretending we now know that they
agreed yeah Trump really won it was
stolen Joe Biden didn't really win and
privately they were texting each other
saying these people are crazy this
doesn't make any sense take a look at
this you knew the
reason so this is a caller to Hannity's
show a few days ago no if you listen to
what I said on the air every day what
did I talk about let me remind you many
Americans do not believe that this
election was fair I feel that way wow
it's a corrupt and an embarrassing
disgrace I'm asking you if you all knew
that the election wasn't stolen from
Trump and yet you are no no no you're
not listening to what I'm saying I said
I had problems that there were Integrity
issues our Dominion systems prone to
human error 72 million Americans voted
for Donald Trump all of them all of us
deserve an answer
right so this is just a sampling of the
placating that Hannity did so listen
um it's at this point there really isn't
a question we know that people like
Hannity and Ingram and Tucker Carlson
are entertainers and they are
propagandists and at the time the way
the wind was blowing they couldn't come
out and say guys
Trump lost that's it that's what they
knew that's what they believed that's
what they said privately Trump lost Joe
Biden won
but they're not in a position to
actually say that to Their audience
because there were 63 lawsuits and they
were their producers were booking guests
for them like Sydney Powell and Rudy
Giuliani and the entire thing so they
did what they had to do as entertainers
while privately there had they had their
views about the facts of the matter this
proves to us they aren't true believers
when it comes to someone like Sydney
Powell that cookie lawyer who has been
disbarred now from multiple uh bar
associations
she does seem like a True Believer she
actually seems insane she raises
religious aspects to what she did and
believes and all these she seems
genuinely out of her mind like a True
Believer but Hannity Tucker Ingram and
others they didn't believe it we
suspected they didn't believe it they
wanted to maintain their audiences they
wanted to maintain their jobs and their
incomes and probably in many of these
cases they wanted to maintain
friendliness with Donald Trump himself
good for this caller for confronting
Hannity we will see what the
repercussions are but I'm increasingly
reading legal analyzes that suggest Fox
News could really really really be in
trouble here this is not you know it yes
Rupert Murdoch has the money to pay the
defamation lawsuit
but that this could
significantly hurt Fox News depending on
what happens and that would be great and
it's not about me saying you know I know
that they're I'm already getting
messages from right winger saying David
you're just advocating for censorship
when you say I hope this lawsuit is
terrible for Fox News you're advocating
for them to be censored no no no
we are talking here about consequences
to defamation consequences to defamation
we're talking about a legal system and a
legal structure here I am a defender of
Fox News being allowed to say whatever
they want to say but there are certain
things they can say which could have
consequences if some of their speech is
defamatory there is a legal process that
is part of our judicial system that
would hold them accountable so what I am
talking about what I am pushing for is
accountability it is not about revenge
censorship or curtailing Free Speech Fox
News did this thing they have been sued
and it is now in the courts to figure
out what the repercussions should be
maybe tomorrow maybe Wednesday I will do
a deeper dive into how this might
actually destroy Fox News we have a
voicemail number that number is 219 to
David p i I think this is the friendly
this is a voicemail that is praising me
I don't think we've ever had a voicemail
with this much praise that needed this
many bleeps we've gotten a lot of hate
messages that need bleeps but never
praise that needs this many bleeps take
a listen to this
uh hey David this is uh Lamaze I've been
listening for a little minute now yeah
I'm from Philly so a little minute just
means a long period of time I don't know
why we do that but that's just something
we do anyway I just wanted to say I
think you actually doing great you're
doing God's word for real for real if I
was to tell you the truth like I think
you out here doing God's work but I what
I don't like about this show and this is
not a knock on you at all
the white people that come to me calling
saying she's not even watching all of
your content like you can tell that they
don't watch it and they just wanted to
call to harass you like at least I'm
going to harass you uplifting you I'm
not you know calling to just harass you
and be like oh
with you that that's weird like but
anyway I think the show was great I
think you're doing a phenomenal job and
I want you to keep it up buddy all right
thank you have a good one well I
appreciate the praise really putting uh
Pat to work there making this radio and
FCC friendly for our radio broadcast
here is what I would say about this I
agree completely that there is something
really sad and depressing about people
who spend so much time writing me these
long hate emails or leaving me these
long hate voicemails not only in
reaction to things I've said but barely
paying attention to things that I've
actually said and as you know we have a
lot of different trolls and people who
call in and they attack me for things I
have not actually said and what I go
back to is I actually feel bad for them
you know sometimes I'll get one of these
messages and I'll go oh that really
bothers me and then I'll say wait a
second
how sad of a life must someone have that
they go hey you know what I think I'm
gonna get my phone out and leave three
three-minute voicemails swearing and
making a fool out of myself for someone
I don't even know and I realize they
must lead truly sad and depressing lives
and I end up feeling bad for them and I
think uh the caller makes that point
very very well we have a great bonus
show for you today we are going to talk
about a video that appears to show
another one of these people trying to
pass bills against drag dressed in drag
this one is from Texas the last one was
from Tennessee this one's from Texas
secondly Kerry Lake not Nikki Haley won
the CPAC vice presidential poll topping
Ron DeSantis topping Nikki Haley it is
another sign that CPAC is still full
Maga and then thirdly former Maryland
Republican Governor Larry Hogan says he
will not be challenging Donald Trump in
the 2024 primary fine not a big deal but
his reasons as to why are super super
interesting sign up at joinpakman.com to
get access to those discussions on the
bonus show you can use the coupon code
24 starts now all one word all lower
case this is the best way you can
support the work we do join pacman.com
coupon code 24 starts now remember
make your voice heard for free
by making sure you're subscribed to our
YouTube channel at youtube.com the
davidpackman show like our videos leave
a comment and also don't forget that
much of our content now available in
Spanish at davidpackman.com Spanish see
you on the bonus show it's just the
beginning of a great week of programs
for you
foreign